in the automotive world supercars are
debuted at international auto shows
Frankfurt Paris Detroit but through your
passion for racing on Xbox and PC forts
a-- has become the premier partner to
the automotive industry so today for the
first time in history a flagship
supercar is making its world debut here
at e3 in front of you this year we
announced a six-year partnership with
Porsche to bring you amazing experiences
both in-game and in person Porsche
shares our vision for the future of
racing and eSports and this car has
never been seen outside of the guarded
walls of Porsche that honor belongs to
you exclusively ladies and gentlemen may
I present the 2018 Porsche 911 gt2 RS
[Music]
this is not only the most aggressive
expression of porcius legendary design
it features the most powerful road-going
911 engine ever made like the xbox 1x
it's a monster and with over 4.8 million
active players across Xbox and Windows
10 Forza is one of the largest racing
communities on the planet you made this
historic moment possible through your
passion for racing the digital and the
real worlds are merging in an
unprecedented way so now let's take a
look at the Porsche 911 gt2 RS in Forza
Motorsport 7 running on Xbox one X I'm
joined on stage by two presenters for
our fourth racing championship eSport
series
I'm Shannon Mackintosh professional
racecar driver and Porsche driving coach
I'll be pushing the gt2 RS to its limits
on the sun-baked streets of Dubai and
divert eat'em a professional racer and
stunt driver I will be fighting to
survive dynamic weather in the
Nurburgring in this Nissan gt-r race car
we start with Shannon and her customized
driver on do by using the power of Xbox
one X quarts of motorsport 7 runs at a
native 4k and a rock-solid 60 frames per
second and we have the additional power
to deliver shocking slow levels of
detail using super high-res lab
resolution assets we've recreated the
intense feel of one of the greatest
driving roads in the world
the habib mountain pass
but in for Tamar's 47 we've reimagined
the entire racing experience on all
devices racing is more immersive and
dynamic ominous skies roll in as car
parts rattle and vibrates we've made
racing more epic and grand race through
living environments featuring
spectacular vistas and massive scale you
can see we made racing more dynamic and
surprising dynamic pummels grow as the
storm unleashes its fury it's more
thrilling and competitive feel the
intense heat grease up your tires as you
battle your rivals and it's more
beautiful and alive dark skies open up
and change as the Sun emerges from the
clouds for a breathtaking finish
[Music]
Racing is reborn in port so whether
running on the Xbox one family of
consoles or Windows 10 pcs Forza
Motorsport 7 is the most technically
advanced and comprehensive racing games
ever made with more than 700 cars it
features the largest collection of
Lamborghinis Ferraris and Porsches ever
assembled
today you are the first people to see
the 2018 Porsche 911 gt2 RS in this week
at e3 like me you can be the first to
drive it so come experience the most
powerful road-going 911 ever made
on the Xbox 1x the most powerful console
ever made in Forza Motorsport 7 thank
you
[Applause]
you